I'm very proud of my son
President Biden reacting for the first
time since the justice department he
oversees criminally charged his son
Hunter Biden he will plead guilty to two
misdemeanor counts of failing to pay his
income tax he will also admit to a
separate felony firearm offense the deal
likely averts time Behind Bars and gives
Hunter probation instead he may also
have to pay a fine some in the media
defending the president's son while
attacking Republicans in the process
Republicans have been trying to stir up
conspiracy theories left and right one
after another have been disproven that's
not going to stop Republicans I venture
to guess I suspect we will have lots of
howling from the GOP House Republicans
are going to keep this up they've
decided to go all in on this as a as a
way to keep the republican-based
enthusiastic these are criminal charges
Republicans will call them a slap on the
wrist you're already hearing a lot of
shouting oh sweetheart deal oh this oh
that this is not a sweetheart deal it's
a deal I think it's a good deal for
Hunter Biden Hunter's lawyer calling the
matter resolved and that the first son
will be taking responsibility for these
mistakes but the doj just like an hour
later said that the investigation is
still ongoing and Republicans are vowing
to plow ahead on investigations into the
Biden family business
leading political opponent doj tries to
literally put you in jail if you are the
president's son you get a sweetheart now
this does nothing to our investigation
it actually should enhance our
investigation because the doj should not
be able to withhold any information now
saying that because the pending
investigation they should be able to
provide chairman coma with any
information that he requires and there's
another major Hunter development get
this the New York Post reporting that
Hunter Biden has privately settled his
child support dispute with the mother of
his unacknowledged four-year-old
daughter and that one really Takes the
Cake we'll get into all of this Jesse
Watters and the News broke during
America's Newsroom I said get Jesse
waters on the phone this is a story for
you well this was not a plea deal this
was a cover-up there's no way this is
going to take five years for a case like
this they didn't even open up the laptop
you
the laptop doesn't even have to exist in
order to hit Hunter Biden with these
charges you open up the laptop and you
have money laundering you have foreign
lobbying crimes you have bribes you have
racketeering
Hunter's lawyer was on MSNBC about an
hour ago and they asked him did they
ever ask you about the laptop and the
lawyer said no
the laptop was never even introduced
into this prosecution so this thing was
siled and mopped up I want to address
something this whole Trump prosecutor
thing that keep people keep saying it's
not really as it seems when the
Republican president is inaugurated he
doesn't say I want that guy to be my U.S
prosecutor out of Delaware he doesn't
even know this guy was how this happens
is the two senators from the state of
Delaware to Democrats select this guy
was it's their idea of a republican
prosecutor and that's how the guys
nominated Coombs and Carper picked this
guy was all right
regular Americans look at this and they
say do you think I'd be able to not pay
income taxes for two years and then
brandish an illegal firearm in front of
a pile of crack cocaine and and
trafficked escorts hell no
any good prosecutor would charge this
guy with income tax evasion and ask the
question where'd the income come from
well the income came from all these
foreign countries and then they pass it
through a maze of shell companies and
the prosecutor never followed the money
and there's no punishment
in the plea agreement now
this has never been about Hunter this
has always been about Joe Biden Hunter
was never going to go to prison whether
it was a plea bargain or a pardon
there's still an active investigation
going on with House Republicans and they
are uncovering new things this afternoon
judge I can't wait to get your thoughts
one thing I wondered about your position
on this debate it was it a sweetheart
deal standard practice or was it a harsh
sentence as some on the left claim I
have never been more certain of a dual
system of justice in this country than I
am today
uh there's no question this was a
sweetheart deal and the the man owed a
million two in back taxes for two years
how much money do you have to make to
owe a million to in back taxes okay
where else was he getting the money but
from barisma we know he was making about
60 000 a month from Prisma uh while he
was a crack addict and had no background
in energy other than his father of
course being the point man on energy for
the administration so given that his job
with barisma was not enough to charge
him with tax evasion in the amount of a
tax misdemeanor excuse me in the amount
of 1.2 million where else was he getting
the money to raise him to that level of
taxes owed I think all you need to do is
look at what we have looked at over the
past several months number one Joe Biden
going before or to the president of
Ukraine and saying if you don't get rid
of the prosecutor on my son's company
you're going to withhold a billion
dollars she got six hours to do it okay
all of a sudden the prosecutor's gone
now Hunter's able to to take care of his
job then we are about a 10 23 and we
hear about phone calls at 10 23 is
during the same two-year period that
this tax evasion or tax crime it's not
even tax evasion comes from the tax uh
crime is for
2017-2018. it was during 2017 that that
conversation was had with the president
of barisma who allegedly tape recorded
the conversations with Joe and with
Hunter saying 5 million each I'm taking
this I'm taping this recording because I
need to know that I can be certain that
I'm going to get results that makes
sense in terms of where the money's
coming from because the guy's a crack
addict now you also have a crack addict
who lies on a pistol permit application
and he gets a gun it's a felony but it
doesn't end there he allows that gun to
be taken by someone else who puts it in
a garbage can that's a reckless handling
of a gun that is not protecting your
weapon and then what he does is he sends
another person to find that gun in a
garbage can near his school and when she
can't find it they send the Secret
Service it is at this point that his
father is no longer in a vice president
and he is not allowed Secret Service
protection so what tentacles did these
bidens have so then what happens is the
Secret Service goes to get a copy of the
pistol permit application from the gun
owner because they're trying to cover it
up and the gun owner the guy who owns
the store says no freaking way you're
not getting this application so you got
a crack addict who says he's not a drug
addict Who Lies he gets a gun and then
they give him a break because he's a
crack addict okay they say we're going
to let you go on diversion no search
warrant no early morning raise no jail
time let me tell you something about
this he's a foreign lobbyist Paul
manafort was in solitary confinement
before he was even convicted as a
foreign lobbyist this guy was a foreign
lobbyist uh Alan weisenberg with Trump
if you're on the Trump side he took a
car that he was he was loaned and a
child that got tuition at a school he's
in Rikers Island the guy is 77 years old
he's in Rikers Island the left are a
bunch of haters this isn't just a crime
against the uh uh uh uh Joe Biden and
everyone else's crime against America
they're taking us down Greg what about
the Democrats especially Joe Biden and
he says he wants to be tough on tax
cheats and gun crimes yeah
hypocrisy there don't you think Dana
yeah I just learned a lot just now that
like if I'm going to commit crime I
should do some crack first right because
then if I do the crack then I could say
I have a problem and then they do this
diversion thing so always have crack
with you when you're committing a crime
Hunter's guilty of a lot of crimes but
except for one he's not a Republican and
he it is a he's guilty of privilege but
it's not white privilege it's Democrat
privilege that's why I'm not outraged by
this I guess because I've kind of
accepted that as a reality it's like
whenever you turned on the other
networks during the Trump era they're
always pulling their hair out over the
same thing every day every day every day
but we already knew what Trump was we
already know what this system is you
know the Democrats the Republicans are
always guilty of subjective crimes right
it's like ah Insurrection a coup hate
speech it's like subjective it's what
you believe it's not objective Democrats
are actually like Hunter guilty of
objective crimes I mean these are actual
crimes but then they're dismissed and
they reject these objective crimes
sometimes you know shoplifting really
isn't a crime uh rioting and looting
mostly peaceful that's just a way to to
represent your outrage age wildfire
wildfire arson suddenly became climate
change so all objective crimes don't
matter subjective crimes matter I think
that love them or hate him and I'm going
to go bring this back to Trump he was
that kind of outside all of this in a
way and I think that's why he was such a
lethal risk he wasn't an elite he had no
relatives in power he was the
anti-hunter so he didn't have friends in
high places he didn't have any relatives
that were in politics and he was already
rich so no wonder he was a target for
Destruction he was a threat
all great points here so far Jessica
little lady um yeah thank you I love
that such a compliment
um today
with these plea this plea deal on tax
evasion and gun crimes and then we get
late this afternoon this announcement of
a settlement with the woman who he
fathered a baby with
that it's a financial settlement he's
only gonna have to pay five thousand
dollars a month not the twenty thousand
dollars a month I don't know what the
other parts of the settlement are but
what we can say is it would be Priceless
to get to know your dad and even your
grandfather that's not going to happen
it doesn't seem like but today I felt
like is the first true day of the Joe
Biden reelection campaign am I correct
yes yeah I could I could it's certainly
been trickling out since Saturday which
was the first official campaign event
and then Hunter was going to be a major
talking point on the campaign and that
is slowly going away but for good reason
so to try to tackle all the points that
everybody made which were aplenty so
what Hunter is not guilty of is being a
republican but there's a republican very
closely allied with Trump named Roger
Stone who did worse than Hunter Biden so
he tax evaded two million dollars not
1.2 million two million dollars and
guess what happened he was allowed to
pay it back and he wasn't even
criminally charged Hunter Biden
criminally in charge could face
probation Roger Stone top guy to Donald
Trump
skates free on that it seems didn't they
rate his house yeah I was just going to
say isn't he the guy
no you you say guns are blazing about
everyone just because someone is
carrying a gun no one shot up any houses
no one was forced out of their house
they tipped off CNN though
the huge crime of having CNN there okay
but I love the fact that you like guns
now
I I really don't and actually I think
that there should be stricter gun
control in this country but if you look
at the doj records about how often what
Hunter Biden did is actually charged
it's basically no 200. to Lil Wayne
do you notice I didn't interrupt a
single person on the panel so just give
me a second I am so sorry in 2019 there
were 290k 98 cases brought of people
falsifying their gun application records
out of 27 million background checks that
were completed that's the year that
Hunter Biden got that weapon that means
that this is something that doesn't get
charged if you want to say to the doj
you should be charging on this go ahead
and do that but there's no reason that
Hunter Biden should be the exception to
this in terms of David Weiss who you say
was hand selected by the Democrats
Donald Trump said he's someone who
shares his vision for making America
safe again that is a quote
all of their prosecutors in all 50
states Jessica how do I know that if you
die you know a lot of things that I
don't know because they're made up
invented in your head
Hunter Biden's a criminal and they
didn't even bring the laptop into the
case you think that's Justice do you
think that's Justice
I want Brett Bear to add David Weiss to
that incredible list of terrible losers
that Donald Trump gave jobs to and then
has to turn against
it's ridiculous
well how do you feel about the fact that
that gun ended up in a garbage can right
terrible about it all right so that we
should have let that happen
Okay but pre-trial diversion is actually
the method that the GOP likes best and
they feel that way
who's been in the trenches for 30 years
don't tell me what the GOP likes I'm
going to tell you what crimes are
prosecuted that is prosecuted I don't
care what people think every day
no one I'm not giving up on that one you
don't we'll talk about it in the break
because we're getting cut off now but
I'm just telling you look at the dog doj
stats they do not prosecute for this
yeah you actually can't get this plea if
you wave your gun around a pile of
Narcotics Jessica all right that's a doj
statistic okay okay coming up rise of
the unconventional candidates RFK Jr and
Vivek ramaswamy join up where top
candidates wouldn't dare go I winner
Brian Kilmeade I want you to do me a
favor I want you to click to subscribe
to the Fox News YouTube page this is the
only way that I know for sure that
you're not going to miss any great
commentary any great news bites any
great interviews coming your way on Fox
you can get it all here on YouTube so
subscribe right now